so after that we see Audrey as she comes
across mr. Tackett open hump a shire
rikki-tikki hamster master Polly wolly
wanna bing bang supercalifragilistic
knick-knack paddywhack give the dog a
banana fanna fo fresca hickory dickory
hockety pockety wacky wacky Angelina
Francesca the third citta police
whatever
and she comes across mr. TECA Nova
humping Shire and she comes across mr.
TECA novan hump a shire rikki-tikki
hamster Panzer any supercalifragilistic
knick-knack paddywhack give the dagger
for fresca hickory dickory hockety
pockety Wagga Wagga
hickory dickory hockety pockety walking
back actually comes across mr. Brett
realistic knick-knack patty-whack he did
supercalifragilistic knick-knack
paddywhack you whack away ah ha ha
and she comes across mr. Tackett over
hop a shire rickety and she comes across
mr. Tackett open hump a shire
rikki-tikki hamster master Polly wanna
wander
hello and she comes across mr. Tekin
oven hump a shire rikki-tikki hamster
master Polly wolly wanna bing bang
supercalifragilistic and she comes
across mr. Tekin oven humpin Shire
rikki-tikki hamster master Polly wolly
wannabe and she comes across mr. Tackett
oven huh Bashara freaky-deaky hamster
master Polly wolly wanna bing bang
supercalifragilistic knick-knack
patty-whack give a dog a banana fanna fo
fresca hickory dickory hockety pockety
wackety wagon DeAngelo fresca and she
comes across mr. tak and open hump a
shire rikki-tikki hamster master Polly
wolly wanna bing bang
supercalifragilistic knick-knack
patty-whack give a dog a banana fanna fo
fresca hickory dickory hockety pockety
Wacka Wacka Angelina Francesca the third